[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlichen dank
dankeschön freue mich sehr hier zu sein
an gott die totale institute in
rüschlikon schön sind sie hier ich freue
mich willkommen auch ihnen zu hause
ja wir wissen es längst wir leben im
post faktischen zeitalter man könnte
auch sagen im zeitalter von pippi
langstrumpf die frisch fröhlich singt
ich mach mir die welt widdewidde wie sie
mir gefällt
doch während uns die anrührt weil sie
mit ihren fantasie geschichten stets für
das gute kämpft sind uns die feschen
jungs von internet trollen weniger
geheuer
doch steckt die wahrheit damit schon in
der krise und worin bestünde denn eine
solche krise darüber spreche ich jetzt
mit lauren tasten sie ist direktorin am
max planck institut für
wissenschaftsgeschichte in berlin und
mit ilja trojanow ist schriftsteller und
essayist der übrigens diesen freitag den
heinrich böll preis entgegennehmen
durfte ganz herzlich willkommen
v dessen ich habe schon gesagt man sagt
die wahrheit stecke in einer krise wie
sieht denn diese krise auch wenn sie
darauf blicken
zuerst für sich sorgen es ist keine
krise der wahrheit keine krise der
fakten die wahrheiten die fakten sind
was sie immer waren es ist eine krise
von wissen und die quellen von wissen es
ist auch eine krise von vertrauen wem
dürfen wir vertrauen und eine krise auch
vielleicht von medienbildung wie gehen
wir mit den neuen medien
es ist so dass es immer wieder den
vorwurf gibt in letzter zeit dass die
kulturwissenschaften irgendwie auch mit
schuld daran sind an dieser krise wie
auch immer die jetzt geartet ist indem
man nämlich gesagt habe wir haben es
übertrieben mit ihrem konstruktivismus
die hatten plötzlich so die idee
eigentlich gibt es gar keine fakten es
gibt keine wahrheit sondern alles ist
einfach perspektive wenn sie diesen
vorwurf zu stimmen nein ich finde das
eine art wahnsinn
seitens der geisteswissenschaften dass
sie so einflussreich sind
ich bin amerikanerin ich würde mich sehr
freuen wenn ich dachte dass ein kongress
man zum beispiel ein werk von
konstruktion asmus je in der hand gehabt
hat
nein dass das klappt ich wirklich nicht
ich glaube dass die ursache dafür
wirklich medien bezogen sind und auch
teilweise gell bezogen sind
man darf nicht unterschätzen inwiefern
jetzt die medien insbesondere in usa
durch geld gesteuert werden über die
medien möchte ich später noch mit ihnen
sprechen bei mir noch kurz bei den
kulturwissenschaften und diesen
konstruktivismus wie sehen sie verteuern
auf naja also der der radikale die
radikale